let's talk about the convention of
states so you know we've been talking
about first the potential for
international conflict but that leads us
into internal conflict
people believing fake news
we've got a problem in the federal
government people aren't feeling that
they're being represented there's a lot
of uh people who wonder if a convention
of states it's uh was it article five
conventional states to amend the
constitution i think yep that's exactly
right let me pull this story from
business inside this is business insider
trump tied conservatives are 15 states
away from an unprecedented rerun
i don't know i don't know if trump would
call me a tied conservative i thought i
thought you guys were right i mean i'm
surprised to hear that you're now we're
trump baseball
trump conservatives so there you go so
15 states are away from an unprecedented
constitutional convention now i bring up
this article simply because
they're shocked
they're worried there may be
constitutional amendments at the state
level i think it's fantastic
so
what is this con you know is they're
they're freaked out obviously they think
it's a bad thing we've had people
already saying they're concerned that if
you get uniparty establishment types to
have the power of a convention of states
it's going to be gutting the
constitution
my view on that one my my counter before
i'll throw it to you guys is the state
level guys aren't the federal level
establishment rhinos people working at
the state level are voted by voted in by
much smaller uh amounts of people so
when it comes to a convention of states
you've got state reps state legislators
so these are these are local guys
what why is that you guys want this what
are your thoughts on is it good or bad
obviously i think first of all one of
the most telling things about that
business insider article there's a
statement of absolute horror that
congress couldn't control it the
president couldn't control it and the
courts couldn't control it you mean the
central government could not act oh my
god what are we going to do horrif
absolute horror right so i i literally
saw that article to hit peace against us
and i thought this is fantastic it's
against you it's a hippie against you
guys specifically yeah against
convention of states a group with ties
to trump's orbit that would be out and
corporate america is leading the push
for america donald trump is like get out
of here you guys i don't even want you
here i love it corporate america i do
occasionally go to grocery stores owned
by corporations and i mean that's my
type
to my tie to corporate america i drive a
car that was produced by that's about it
really this is a grassroots group
they're over 5.2 million people involved
just regular folks all over the country
they're actually in every single state
legislative district in the united
states of america and i understand why
the establishment is terrified of this
and by the way there's plenty of
establishment on the right that is
terrified of this too they don't want us
taking their power away and giving it
back to the people that's the entire
purpose of this the founders intended it
for right now this gets in the
constitution in 1787 colonel george
mason from virginia stands up two days
before the end of convention he says
this is terrible we drafted a document
doesn't give the power to the people to
propose amendments but we gave that
power to congress and he asks are we so
naive that we believe that a government
that becomes a tyranny will restrain its
own tyranny wow gotta give the power to
the people right and in fact it's really
weird in madison's notes that's where we
know everything that happened from the
convention all it says right there is
nincom latin abbreviation for no comment
not one guy in that room said george
that's such a stupid idea everybody was
a forehead slap i think they probably
laughed in that moment so they put in
the second clause of article 5 saying
someday federal government's going to
get out of control we're going to count
on you folks in the states to handle it
are they gonna yeah
well let me just a little further that
that the if you read anything about the
founding that the founders were fixated
on checks and balances they wanted to to
have each branch of government check
each other they wanted have the states
to be a check
they were concerned about the
aggregation of power into
a central government or particularly
because they came from
places where there were kings and
emperors they didn't want that power to
all be in one place because they knew
eventually tyranny would be taken over
and the president or leader at the time
would would would do that and and so
they put in
the united states senate as a check and
the biggest check was that the united
states senate was going to be appointed
by the state legislatures yep and people
forget that for the first 140 years of
the republic
washington d.c was a backwater town with
no power
it was yeah it wasn't important you know
what the largest source of revenue for
the federal government was before the
17th amendment which which changed the
way senators were elected were like
selling booze or something exactly was
the tax on alcohol the reason the reason
we got the income tax
is because of the temperance movement
because the the the temperature could
never pass and wash it the prohibition
couldn't pass in washington because they
couldn't give up the tax on alcohol so
they trade that the conservatives traded
their vote for the income tax in
exchange for prohibition so we got the
worst of both worlds in my opinion but
anyway they
they also passed a constitutional
amendment to
change the way senators were elected to
instead of having the states checking
washington from doing things to take the
power away from them and the people now
it's the people that elected the senate
so they took away the biggest check on
power right of washington d.c and so
this is the only other piece of the
constitution left
to check power from the states is
article 5 and a convention of states i
think it was ben sas who said maybe like
a year ago that we should repeal the
17th oh absolutely return return the
senate the senate
i would i would before that it has no
chance of it yeah i agree i completely
agree people understand there's a lot of
people who look at single-layer issues
the surface the people choose centers
it's way better oh it sounds way better
and they say the the idea that only the
legislators would be able to appoint
their friends no no listen
people have lost their connection with
their local politics because there's no
skin in the game anymore right and
it not only did the 17th
gut state power to that regard it
weakened article 5 as well because
people aren't paying attention to their
local races anymore and the most
important too so i i'll throw it to you
know for one i i when i first heard him
say that i was like what why would you
want that i mean the initial idea was
that better men would appoint senators
and that sounds pretentious and elitist
and then you think about the math of it
the logic and you're like
people need to be focused on their
states
we hear it all the time for members of
congress they're running for election
and they're like in our town crime is up
x percent when i get to washington i'm
going to clean this town up it's like no
you're not you're going to the federal
government to vote in federal policy
right our local elected representatives
are going to fix that problem but people
lost that connection
so
i i would be for that um i love the idea
of a convention of states my one fear
is it utopian like you know because i'll
tell you this you know what i'd love to
see
i'd love to see a convention of states
happens
the states are all predominantly
conservative which means there's a bunch
of things i like probably a lot of
things i wouldn't agree with being more
moderate but uh gun rights for instance
i'd love to just see them be like hey
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
issue an amendment and says to reaffirm
the second amendment
citizens of this country can keep and
bear arms of any type or accessory or
otherwise
there you go we've spelled it out and
then just like stamp
but that's utopian right is would
something like that really happen my
fear is
you'll get they'll go in and say we're
going to compromise on the second
amendment and say okay we're going to
restrict these things and make sure it's
codified now the the here's the the one
of the important things well there's
several important things number one is
that the convention is being called
pursuant to a resolution that has to be
adopted as you see on that map by by 34
states and the resolution calling the
convention is the governing document of
the convention
and that resolution and mark can go
through it because he knows it inside
out better than i do but that resolution
is a is a resolution that
says three types of amendments are
eligible all three types of amendments
are limiting
amendments amendments that limit the
power and jurisdiction of the federal
government or spending of the federal
government so an amendment offered at
that convention
that
compromises as you say on the on on the
second amendment and weakens the second
amendment would thereby strengthen the
federal government and would be out of
order at the convention what if they
argued that the constitution as a facet
of government is being limited
by taking out some of its protections
the the application the resolutions
themselves specifically say that they're
intended to limit the scope the power
and the jurisdiction of the federal
government so if it's not taking power
away from the federal government and
returning to the people
it would be what's called non-germain in
legal terms and and i want to
address something much more practical
than that
it's important that people understand i
hear that people are afraid of
convention convention is a place to get
together have a debate and make some
suggestions now i can tell you in my
entire adult life i've never had anybody
say hey i'd like to go to a meeting
we're going to sit around a table going
to make some suggestions and my response
was oh my god that's so terrifying
please don't have a discussion because
what comes out of convention has to be
ratified by 38 states and i'd throw this
out to your people who are watching the
podcast right now that might be worried
about this i've said this to literally
millions of people on the air
my personal email address meckler at
cosaction.com if you're concerned about
this then just in layman's terms send me
the amendment you're worried about
and on the bottom of that list the 38
states that'll ratify it and the answer
is i've offered that to millions of
people i've not received an email
because it's impossible we're talking
about the second amendment today there
are actually 24 states in which you can
carry your handgun in the capital i know
i've done it in most of them there are
14 states where you can take a loaded ar
sling it across your back and sit in the
gallery and watch the proceedings it
takes only 13 states to stop any
amendment are you telling me we can't
get 13 states to limit or to stop an
amendment to to do anything to the
second it makes no sense i'm i'm i'm
for convention of states for one simple
reason this ain't working exactly like
we we we think we're gonna elect these
people nancy pelosi she can't lose
she even said she held up a glass of
water and said you put a glass of water
in my or aoc's district you put a d on
it it's going to get elected that's true
yeah something's got to change something
the reality is that we know where
america is headed and it isn't a pretty
place we are seeing more and more
centralization of power we are seeing
our freedoms being violated we've seen
our culture becoming more and more woke
and the reality is and and lives just
even the more the biggest reality with
31 trillion dollars in debt i mean just
a few years ago we were like six and all
of a sudden we're like 30 trillion and
and by the way we're looking at 40 50
at some point this this house of cards
falls apart and we're sitting here
saying well we'll trust washington to
fix that
does anyone actually believe they will
fix it no no one does so what are you
afraid of are you afraid of a group of
legislators getting together and and and
offering up proposals because again you
read the constitutional language the
convention can propose amendments that's
it shall call a convention for proposing
amendments that's the quote from article
5. so they don't ratify anything they
simply offer up suggestions that go to
the states for ratification and do i
think we'll have dramatic changes at
this convention or
proposals that will uh fundamentally
change the constitution probably not
practice it's going to be really hard to
get 38 states to ratify anything
but the fact that we would actually call
a convention of states and have a
national discussion i mean imagine
imagine if you know next week or next
month
a convention was being called to by and
having all 50 states send delegates to
propose amendments to the constitution
everybody would be talking about it'd be
amazing it'd be on the it'd be on the
front page of every paper for for months
we would have groups arguing and forming
to propose amendments and get behind
amendments we'd have actually civics
taught in our schools about what the
constitution is what rights actually are
federal rights what rights are state
rights where are they better situated
how at a time when we are so divided and
so broken having a national conversation
about
who we are and how we'd like to how we'd
like to go forward as a country is
really needed what if you guys could
propose like
in your minds the the amendments that
should be proposed what do you think
yeah i mean i think some of them are
obvious that most people talk about one
you hear all the time is some form of
balanced budget amendment and i would
say that's got to be it's got to have
spending caps and and taxation caps tied
to it i mean this this is critical the
folks in washington dc they're never
going to make the hard decisions why
would they they get punished for making
those decisions what oh you want to stop
you want to cut off money to children
and widows and that's how it's always
presented so you put in a structure that
forces them to make the hard decisions i
think that's a no-brainer
term limits for civil servants so this
is one of my favorites and if you look
at our resolution this is really
important it does talk about term limits
but it says term limits for members of
congress
and federal officials and it's exactly
because of what you said because you
don't want to empower the bureaucracy
you don't want to empower the staffers
if you're going to turn congress you
better turn federal officials and by the
way now we know of this as the deep
state that was conspiracy theory stuff a
couple of years ago but so you can turn
out the deep state when these people are
in dc for 30 years 35 years
they have the power and they have more
power than the politicians and they're
unaccountable and unelected yeah i'll
throw a couple at you one i think
actually could pass and i know uh there
are people who might question that which
is
to limit the supreme court to nine
members
uh and
certainly every republican would vote
for every republican but i look
there are some fringe people on the
democratic side who are for court
packing
but the vast majority of
democrats out there across the country
realize that if we start this game of
the democrats adding four and then the
republicans adding it's it's a zoo and
and so
putting that in the constitution would
be if that's the only thing that comes
out of the convention that actually and
it would there's no question that will
come out of the convention if that's the
only thing that happens that would
actually be a good thing and a
stabilizing thing something we can all
sort of agree on
and by the way having something that we
can all agree on that's a big deal is
good for a country every now and then
you don't see it happen very much the
other thing i think too the point you
guys made about the 38 states is that
these are conservative states that are
that are gearing up towards this it's
not like new york 30 31 of the of the 50
states right now the legislatures are
controlled by republicans that's going
to go to at least 32 or 33 this year and
maybe more and with virginia which is
one uh one house is controlled by
republicans one is one shortened uh in
in the uh in the senate uh
you can have 34 states controlled by
republicans and if that happens
we need 34 states to get to uh to to a a
resolution pass to have this convention
called we could have this convention
called an in a year or two but you'll
need 38 to ratify it but again
i'm i'd love to see like i said i'd love
to see the court packing thing and i'd
love to see for example the federal
government should play no role in
primary and secondary education and
you'd say well that'd have no chance of
passing i don't know if i'm connecticut
or california
i don't want donald trump or rick
santorum coming into washington d.c
telling me how to run my schools anymore
that if i'm in alabama i want joe biden
tell me how to run my school so you'd be
surprised remember these are state
legislators not congressmen and senators
you'd be surprised how many legislators
would say you know what we don't want
the federal government telling us what
to do and so don't be surprised that
there will be more things that could
limit the power of the federal
government that actually could be
adopted even when you need 38 years to
do it let me give you a real easy one
that most people don't talk about it's
called a single subject amendment a lot
of states have this and people are
furious you get these omnibus bills
they're 2 000 pages that no one has read
no one and no one could read them to be
realistic and honestly if you've ever
tried what you would find is there's so
many references to other statutes and
portions of the you can't nobody can
understand them right yeah so a single
subject commitment says one thing per
bill
and the american people if you ask them
it's 99 of the american people would say
yeah absolutely we can ratify that
easily
i wonder
how is it that we get this omnibus
spending bill it's like 5 000 pages who
writes that and why do why do people
vote on i mean you've got experience
there uh
well every every year the congress is
supposed to pass 13 bills to spend spend
the money and what happens is uh that
takes a lot of time and it takes a lot
of time on the floor of the house and
senate and they don't want to spend all
the time talking about those things so
in the end they put it up all into one
bill it's called an omnibus bill because
they didn't pass all the 13 they may
have passed two or three of them but
there's like random weird stuff thrown
in these things it's it look
it is a process by which you have to get
218 votes in the house and 51 votes in
the senate and or or more in some cases
60 votes in the senate so what do you do
your horse trade
and you say you want you know i don't
want to vote for this well how about if
i give you this okay i'll vote for it
wow i mean
that's the way things get done it's sort
of i don't know if you're married but
sometimes you gotta have to you know
give and take a little bit if you're
gonna get things done and that's that's
how the process works we like to talk
about guns is a really good example of
how different people live different
lives in different terrains right so if
you live in the mountains for instance
well we got bears out here you know you
certainly want to have some kind of
protection for yourself i don't know how
you deal with an actual bear because you
don't need a big gun you might not carry
them but uh a raccoon or a fox right
maybe uh we've had raccoons out here and
you know you don't want to be
chased by one should it be ravenous or
whatever you know coyotes coyotes for
instance the chickens uh you live in new
york city i get it you don't want a gun
you know and then people are shooting
each other fine i think the second
amendment you know is for the entire
country including new york and the
people who live there have the right to
defend themselves yeah but the idea we
often bring up is that the people in new
york city who don't like guns vote for
people in west virginia which makes no
sense i'll give you a better example as
air conditioning you got the people in
the blue areas who are like you know we
don't need air conditioning it's a
luxury it's bad for the climate and the
people in miami are like how dare you
because they couldn't live in miami they
got a statue the guy who invented air
conditioning down there texas just
secedes they're like yeah
we're out we're out we need it we can't
live without it so you know that's
that's that's not the same as a weapon
but that shows you that if you live in a
cooler climate with less hot days you're
probably thinking to yourself who needs
this stuff that's fine well that's fine
if we're going to get rid of air
conditioning in the south we'll get rid
of heat in the north
oh yeah exactly yeah
you know he burns as much energy as air
conditioning right but
same process it sounds like that's the
the problem with compromise because
you're in you're in you know office and
someone says i want to spend x amount of
dollars in this place for this reason
you're like well that doesn't matter
that much to me give me this and i'll do
it you you basically start getting these
weird policies that that's why you have
to take the jurisdiction away from the
government it's you're never gonna look
any
that's happened since the beginning of
the republic they've always been horse
trading that
it ha it has to be that way and and you
can make the argument that it actually
reflects the needs of the different
parts of the country because you horse
straight for something that i want in
alabama that you need in new york
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that what's wrong is that they shouldn't
have the jurisdiction to do
it things that that that are not within
the federal government's purview yeah
the question is how much power do they
have right i mean that's what if you
take the power away then you limit the
amount of horse trading that goes on to
the things that are more fundamental to
the federal and honestly most people
then wouldn't care about what goes on in
washington dc which is really how it was
always intended to be what you were
supposed to care about were your local
politics what what was the local school
board doing what's your city council or
township doing those were the things
that were supposed to affect you as a
citizen the founders would be stunned
that we allow so much stuff to happen in
washington the federal government was
supposed to care of making making sure
that we were safe from foreign threats
that there was interstate commerce that
could flow between the two and that we
had some trade policy to make sure that
we you know were able to trade goods
goods and services back and forth and
we've gone way beyond and the answer is
to pull it back thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there